and there's two types of debt there's
good debt and there's bad debt good debt
is where you take out a loan and that
money that you take out that debt you
use to get you rich so an example would
be I got a loan for
£15,000 when I was about 19 years old
and that loan that I got for £15,000 I
used it as a deposit to buy a house now
my interest on the £15,000 was only 10%
so I'm having to pay
£1,500 a year I'm having to pay an
interest back to the bank however I now
own a house and my profit is way more
than £1,500 a year it's more like £5,000
a year I'm using the profit number one
to reinvest and to save and to live off
but I'm only using a small portion of it
to service the debt so debt is your best
friend